[Music]
give Denmark's John Calmar just an inch
and he'll punch a concrete block in half
that is one powerful punch there has to
be a more efficient way to cut concrete
you doesn't actually have grey hair he's
actually just covered in cinder block
dust how is John able to smash these
slabs from such a short distance the
faster a fist is moving the more
powerful the punch and for a normal
punch there's a reasonable run-up for
the fist to get up to speed John has
trained his muscles to make his fists
accelerate up to 7 miles per hour
11 km/h in a millisecond producing a
huge amount of force in just the blink
of an eye John is punching it with a
force of at least 1900 Newtons an
average person's punch is only a
thousand Newtons so John is punching
with twice the average force over only
an inch
John is careful to train his one-inch
punch at the point where the force is
absorbed the greatest and that happens
to be right in the middle the farthest
point from the two supports it has taken
years of practice for John to hone his
one-inch punch and it will come in very
handy if he's ever attacked by a
concrete block without much room to move